joining us now the ranking member of the
House Intelligence Committee congressman
Devin Nunez and the freedom caucus
chairman mark Meadows I gotta say this
about mark Jim Jordan Devin Nunez will
add Doug Collins to the mix and maybe
Matt Gaetz the freshman he's he's overly
ambitious but a good guy and he's really
done a great job without you guys behind
the scenes because I've now we've now
seen these closed-door testimony without
your efforts we would not be here and
this would have got likely all have
gotten gotten away with and congressman
Nunez a special applause to you tonight
for that speech which I think probably
you're right up there with Lindsey
Graham speech on the day of the Kavanagh
Eric well thank you thank you Sean and
what was amazing to me that I think a
lot of people didn't pay attention to is
there were two retired FBI agents on the
stand there on the witness table along
with Andy McCarthy who's appears a lot
on your show and others what I was
amazed at is the the lack of concern by
these former FBI agents one of whom
Peters Strock used to work for and look
they serve their country and I'm sure
they did a great job but when I brought
up the fact that we probably shouldn't
be using counterintelligence
capabilities in this country to target a
political campaign they just sat there
it was almost like they had been coached
by the Democrats to not say anything bad
about the counterintelligence
investigation that occurred and I'll
tell you if that's the attitude I know
we always say oh this happened at the
very top of the FBI but I will tell you
that's if that attitude permeated
throughout the counterintelligence
capabilities and if retired FBI agents
think it's okay to use
counterintelligence against political
campaigns I think we have we've gone a
long way in this country because they
used to be the Democrats who didn't
support the counterintelligence
capabilities because they thought that
they were spying on their campaigns and
on political enemies it ends up in fact
they took them over they corrupted the
whole thing and it seems like that's the
attitude throughout the FBI at least for
the former and former most of the former
officials really it was a powerful
moving speech he gave today and I will
say this and I mean this is the biggest
compliment to congressman meadows and I
want everybody to understand as the
chairman of freedom caucus what you and
Jim Jordan in particular did behind
closed doors now that
we're getting those transcripts you are
asking the right questions the hardest
questions inform questions and
forward-thinking questions knowing what
the truth would eventually be and come
out as your reaction to all of these
events well thank you Sean I can tell
you Devon Nunez has done an unbelievable
job and actually we've had two different
camps he's seen much of the classified
Jim Jordan and I have not and so we've
been able to work together in a way that
honestly is about transparency for the
American people here's the thing that
that dawned on me today
you had another Muller hearing here and
in hip C and open hearing why was it
open because they want to try to
resurrect the whole Muller narrative and
try to do their best to make sure that
the American people are engaged but the
truth of the matter is they didn't get
the result they wanted you know there
was the Oh Adam you know if at first you
don't succeed try try again well they
tried tried tried and try it again and
they'll continue to try but the problem
is is they know the truth many even some
of the witnesses today here on Capitol
Hill they're supposed to be experts they
hadn't even read that steel dossier
that's how not credible that was that's
pretty amazing too so how are we to
interpret this New York Times news
tonight
do both of you believe as I think I'm
reading and interpreting I always ask
both of you one question because neither
one of you would leak to me the way I
wanted you to I would ask you one
question
you're laughing what's the question am i
over the target am i over the target in
thinking countries like Italy Ally
countries and Great Britain and
Australia maybe were out sourced
intelligence gathering by our
intelligence people to circumvent
American laws Devon Nunez so I think
what we don't know yet is we don't know
who Joseph Mifsud was working for he
could have been he's been described as a
Western intelligence asset he was in
Italy so that for sure brings up he
could be a part of the Italian
government of some kind an asset there
he could be a British asset because he
also lived in London so but there's also
it could be possible
quite frankly that he was working for
fusion GPS or an operation like fusion
GPS through Christopher Steele and what
we what we still don't know at the heart
of this is where did the Clinton
campaign dirty operation that was run by
fusion GPS and the FBI they were on
parallel tracks when did those merge and
that's really what I think myself and
Mark Meadows are have been trying to
figure out for a long time and hopefully
that's what the US Attorney out of
Connecticut is going to get to the
bottom of we have a right to know what
countries were involved in this well
mark yeah Shawn we're getting a lot of
whistleblowers primarily the
whistleblowers are coming forward
because they believe Attorney General
Bill Barr and John Durham are willing to
get to the bottom of it so people that
perhaps were afraid under previous
leadership to actually say well we knew
this was wrong
they're coming forward now and you know
when we look at intelligence we know
that the intelligence community shares a
lot of information what we also know
what Devin unas knows Jim Jordan Mark
meadows and others that have been
involved is that the Steele dossier
Christopher Steele his dossier not only
does it have its origins with fusion GPS
and the Democrat National Committee but
other other players that are connected
Sidney Blumenthal and they were shopping
it to every media outlet that they
possibly could and the FBI knew it
that's the problem the FBI knew it prior
to that first FISA and here here they
are using it as credible information for
a FISA application I just think that
that's totally wrong let me ask you both
the same exit question most people are
asking me when when are they going to be
held accountable what do you see in the
future Devin newness and you know you
know a lot more than I do where do you
see them going and who would you not
want to be tonight in terms of putting
your head down on on pillow for a
peaceful night's sleep well look if
you're any of the former people at the
FBI that we're in in those famous text
messages that marca did such a good job
of getting to the bottom of those people
I think all have to be concerned if you
look at any of the dirty operations arms
of the Clinton campaign and there's a
lot of people that were involved with
the
J involved in that spouses of people of
the DOJ that were involved because
ultimately that steel dossier permeated
down all the way through ultimately to
the Special Counsel and I'll disclose
with this tonight that is that I was
finally able to see the scope memo and
remember I had these concerns that it
was based upon the steel dossier and
look I can't talk about what those in
there but we know from the Moller report
it or from the what Judge Sullivan put
out we know that it was probably largely
based on the still dossier and I think
the Grassley memo and the noonas memo
said something to the effect the bulk of
the information came from that last word
mark listen people need to go to jail
people need to held it be accountable
and I believe indictments are on their
way all right I want to thank you both
that all honesty these two guys we
wouldn't be where we are today getting
to the truth equal justice
constitutional republic they did the
right thing for their country thank you